viser une victoire pour bien commencer
l'année c'était le souhait de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux qui recevait
builly-les-mines à l'occasion de la
dixième journée de Nationale 2 après une
première période équilibrée entre les
deux équipes pour les contacts sont
présents se sont finalement les
illimontaines qui rentrent au vestiaire
avec un but d'avance le score à la poste
14 à 13 sur la première période on était
plutôt bien on était très engagés il y
avait une très bonne défense il y avait
une bonne attaque il y a des petites
erreurs notamment sur les changements de
timing qu'on fait pas forcément sur les
prises intervalles qu'on a pas forcément
dans les dans le dans les bons espaces
sur des lâchés de balles qui sont pas
aussi précises que ce qui faudrait pour
pouvoir avoir une continuité dans le jeu
mais on arrive à peu près à s'en sortir
en général sur les premières mi-temps au
retour des vestiaires la dynamique n'est
pas bonne pour montiller le Bretonneux
au complexe sportif Pierre de Coubertin
et joueuse locale se font dépasser au
tableau d'affichage elle ne reviendront
pas malgré de bonnes séquences les
ebinoises s'inclinent 27 à 25 on perd
encore une fois à domicile mais c'est
encore une fois sur la deuxième mi-temps
sur nos erreurs
on a trois fois plus de perte de balle
en deuxième mi-temps qu'en première
comme les matchs qu'on perd en général
voilà et puis c'est vrai que depuis un
certain temps on avait la meilleure
attaque depuis un certain temps on
n'arrive pas à dépasser la barre des 26
buts forcément on est un peu déçu
puisque on voulait gagner ce premier
match avec cette nouvelle année
mais je pense que on va pouvoir se
relever assez rapidement de ça on va
travailler à l'entraînement on prend
chaque match comme il vient celui-là on
s'est raté mais on va revenir vite dès
la semaine prochaine justement pour pour
juste nous rebooster déjà la semaine
prochaine le 14 janvier est joué Yves
Villenoy se déplaceront sur le terrain
de Corbie à l'occasion de la 11e journée
une rencontre où les inhy Montaine
seront favorites Montigny-le-Bretonneux
occupe actuellement la quatrième place
du classement et son futur adversaire la
dixième